hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to completing the
mission
i hope you played the game i hope you
supported the developer
because they deserve your support and
this game is worth playing
so if you haven't done it yet what is
wrong with you
what did they do full confession
i actually just started recording but i
accidentally left my reverb on i was
previously doing a scary bit i
apparently i can't just i was just
anyway never mind so
we were on relentless bounty hunter
starting with convict
allies it says i already started it but
i only got two choices in
i know what the failures are i don't
know what the success is okay
all right okay let's get into this
i've been actually really looking
forward to this i really really can't
wait to play this
it's hard to wait so long i have a tank
yeah there she is baby you said you
stole this from the top app
what can i say a master thief i think i
heard of them when i was getting locked
up at the wall criminal organization
right and you crossed them
yeah we got to put this bad boy to use
we got to put this bad boy to use
i don't know about you but i'm running
pretty low on cash
i never got enough cash get in touch
with my contacts and find out where
they're at
all right
like i said before right to the secret
base
that can't be comfortable that's it
the transport train i think they're
supposed to be
there it is their money card their money
card i'm pretty sure that cart contains
all the money they've amassed
there's our payday let's take it to him
let's take it to him
let's do this let's get it done
wait you hear that
i don't know damn
damn damn
[Music]
yeah that killed me in one shot last
time i don't know what their deal is
oh this is so epic i i wish this i wish
i wish i hadn't screwed up the recording
oh god oh wait hang on
sorry what i i like i actually cut to
i'll i'll cut and show you what my
actually why don't i just do that i'll
cut and show you my reaction to it it's
got a little reverb
but it's there okay oh god that's so
cool
oh uh well well i just
not this time buddy yeah get sworded
yeah oh betrayal oh no lost
the lead no whoops okay swords hunker
hunker yeah there we go hunker in the
boat it is a tank after all
oh all right cool there it was all right
now i know it's fire
that's me buddy that's me
have the train the train's in trouble i
can't
stop it i'm on the way
i'm sure that's a reference to something
i'm sure
well that's one way to do it that is
out of here
what's a fulton what's a fulton
[Music]
oh what
oh wait wait wait wait what
what hi
wombo
oh my god seems like we're out of the
danger zone uh-huh
but what do we do now oh yeah his legs i
guess
oh i'm done i did it i'm so
good
what well i didn't
what all right fair enough
i didn't i'm the greatest they'll never
find us
capital gains baby all right uh jeez
oh it's one of the shorter ones anyway
okay uh
actually i want to try something real
quick the the i wonder if those actually
were selections
you know the little tiny the the short
term hang on
but i can't do anything
needle what are you doing
oh an idiot only a little bit
only only what was the point of that not
the sharpest idea gonna pin the blame on
you for that one do you really need all
that money okay all right
cursive holding good
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god sorry i didn't expect
force lift
sheet is
oh well well she could bring it back
down
she could bring it back down okay that
was all for that one all right so that
was a short one but that's okay
relentless bounty hunter ghost inmate
gun
yes tank
yes where am i
you've got to be pretty tired of waking
up like this
that's right it's me but you thought you
took me out oh
well nobody gets away from the topic
apparently nobody gets away from the top
claim
oh okay enjoy your stay enjoy my stay
oh god oh i'm actually here
i have the power
[Music]
well i'm out and it was nothing
seems like there's still an imposter
among us wait what
that usually is a thing i don't know
what this is in reference to
okay who'd have thought that the magic
spell would've been the correct answer
oh wow apparently that's good i
did it bomb
yeah technically doors open the melt ray
oh that's so sad awesome
you super stupid metal hat
wow wow hi
henry's escaped he's on his way towards
the main cabin now coming from wing
seven
[Music]
well that's pretty cool oh yes please
smoked himself in armory seven uh
uh yeah big sword
okay
hey i'm a big boy i'm a i'm a big boy
underbarrel grenade launcher
[Music]
oh
i gotta stop doing the explodies it
should be pretty obvious now
but i'm very dumb pew pew gun oh
my oh oh my god
i need an update on that henry situation
[Applause]
that's how it goes man everything around
here
maybe
hello hi oh ow
you should have stayed in yourself maybe
uh sweep the leg
oh now that's cute oh my god
i'm gonna harden oh
oh no nano shoot apparently i had this
the whole time
hello it's not gonna help you maybe you
will
but that's not ah
there you are oh
oh uh
the release mechanism is located near
your thumb on the right it's
instructions i get if you do not
disconnect the missile it may activate
well you're still gonna
i get it yeah i get it yeah max gravity
oh is that good or bad i lost a solar
panel yeah oh no
i'm dealing with it okay don't even get
snippy about it
ah where'd he go
uh earth go for it
you'll be fine
[Laughter]
one of our offsite drop pods is on a
direct collision course with the station
what three two one
hey
i did it i'm the greatest ever
i did it lovely and he's dead oh
i thought he was dead apparently he's
not dead
he took out our central core we don't
have any power
i can't really get down to earth without
it so we're kind of just stuck
who was that guy anyway why'd you why'd
you grab him
well i'm henry stickman i'm a free man
i almost got every failure there i'm
terrible lock pick it
there's no lock to put oh lock pick it
again
lock pick it again
you got to stop trying this man oh
there's something here lock pick it
there is no lot lock pick the lock
lock pick it fine you want to lock yes
there's your lock lock pick it
uh what no but hang on wait
no guy my guy should have just moved on
all right uh disson
i'm here
[Music]
yeah it's me again we're picking up a
data stream from our broadcasting
satellite
you don't say yeah just keep saying
attack attack
attack fire shoot the laser
[Laughter]
fair enough what about this this one
looks like it's got a big beefy missile
that's good yeah
[Music]
oh oh no
i'm sorry international rescue
assisted by charles is that you buddy
charles is that you buddy
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah
there he is charles
[Music]
charles
charles calvin
altitude 20 000 feet wind speed nominal
visibility is clear standby for drop
i hope you don't mind helping us out
again
i called ahead and got the all clear
from the general i'm sure you've got a
lot of questions
don't worry he'll fill you in when you
arrive
you'll be dropping in on the outskirts
at the top at launch site
we've also got a squad waiting for you
when you arrive okay
all right time
there he is do you think he says
legendary
even more so
nice
hi henry yeah really kept us waiting huh
no nice to meet the legend in person
sure is
[Music]
hi henry glad to see you made it safely
let me introduce you to your squad first
off is john
he's been doing this for 30 years and he
excels at stealth
he'll be your go-to man for anything
involving stealth
he'll be going by the code name frog
frog
banks okay so when it comes to
electronics he knows his way around any
interface
and he'll be very helpful when it comes
to hacking okay owned by the code name
eel lastly we have amelia esteban
demolitions expert
she's known to tackle problems head on
and will blow a hole in any problem
her codename turtle turtle general
what's all this about ah frog i'll run
through the briefing again
we recently learned of the topic clint's
plan to launch a space station into
orbit around the earth
if they're able to get this station
operational they'll become unstoppable
they'll be able to attack any place
around the world easily with no way for
anyone to counter-attack
the top ads weren't they brought down by
henry
unfortunately no only the leader was
captured
but now being led by the previous
right-hand man the right-hand man
ah i thought he was defeated seems
someone's fixed him up
giving him cybernetic enhancements to
boo he'll be quite a handful to deal
with
okay so we're just cleaning up another
mess
well it is what you do best it is your
mission is to capture or eliminate the
right-hand man
we'll be launching an all-out assault on
the compound at the same time our focus
being on preventing the rocket from
launching
ah sounds like a good time sounds like a
good
[Music]
good luck out there henry you got it
general
i'm here for you let's get in there and
find it let's do it
we need to get past that guard
ah oh
oh
[Music]
sorry let's convert him
narwini
[Laughter]
give me another chance give me another
chance give me another chance
you should be able to get close without
getting detected
dog give me another chance now
keep the door secure there he is
let's do this let's do this i dance
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
i love it i love the sound of it and i
love what it can do
wait a minute oh
well all right then that's fair
suppressing fire pressing fire
you loop around and get behind him now
go
oh my god
my whole team is dead i was gonna hunt
you down
no into my lap
go on on your feet i'll give you one
shot
oh yeah oh hell yeah dance off baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
how about chief fighting combo yeah yeah
uh-huh
[Music]
oh god
i love it i'm the greatest who's that
he's got the boss no no i don't dance
off baby
rewire hey it's me i'm fine
henry we gotta put a stop to these
topics come on
never mind guess the leaders got him
yeah oh god i'm so genius
the top beds are finished you're not
going anywhere
what is happening stand back henry
i'll take care of this guy excellent
you're our boss you're really gonna side
with the guy who locked up the chief
[Laughter]
oh
man i thought that was it i i thought i
was like oh hell yeah
uh finish him
oh no he's killed him
oh well yo he's needing a new boss man
[Music]
well that's sad i guess fitting ocarina
this is better than a dance-off surely
[Music]
i played charles song charles charles
hi oh i thought i was gonna die
oh i did it but i didn't get to dance
put out the signal and all my team is
dead
what do we do yo we like a new boss man
oh man i'll lead us through this ah no i
will
is anyone there we need to take off
immediately who put you in charge
got another group that surrendered here
nice
thanks charles excellent job henry thank
you it's too bad about all
of my team dying and we were able to
prevent the rocket from launching
a few members escaped but they're all in
small groups now
they won't be causing us any significant
problems you know
bounty hunting really suits you never
think about going pro
hmm not bad not bad
not bad master bounty hunter that's me
okay i missed uh actually that was i
thought that was a longer one
stealth wow
oh close quarters coming
hi yeah oh
all right that's fair enough okay uh is
up just
oh all right fair enough
rock paper scissors
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay all right that's it for that one oh
no we're running out oh
man we're almost out what did we do for
this one we did the betrayed okay
okay let's go presume dead
hi
hello hi
listen listen the top back clan
won't even stand a chance against us
dude
yeah they don't even realize
that that we know about their secret
juggle base
they think they can just launch a rocket
into
orbit and be free to do whatever they
want
just we're gonna even show that what are
you two idiots
doing we need to ship out right now
you guys are the worst you're not
charlie come
on you're not charles
hey yeah
wait if i'm already part of the topic
that was too early oh
sorry that caught me off guard wait if i
part of the top hat wouldn't i already
be there abuse physics engine
hello excellent
heard the new top bad leaders that works
buck says he shows up and stops our
entire operation
ten bucks all right all right
sure hmm oh
knife
ow wow duplicate orange
oh this can be good well
i was about to say i was literally gonna
say how do we know that's a real henry
not gonna follow some duplicate some
stupid duplicate lag switch
you'll never never gonna get it never
ever gonna get me
you will this stupid idiot stupid idiot
what a stupid wow i did not notice a
gigantic tank last time
uh scrambler
oh my god
i love big boy
hi oh chaos containment
hello uh come in command we are picking
up minor chaos readings here
no permission to engage no
roger that commencing chaos containment
damn it fine what is this
love it's not love it's the opposite of
love
it's the opposite of love it's not love
oh my god
you should have thought about what i'm
willing to do in order to get the job
done
um that oh it's majora's mask it's
it's not love cold
commencing ultimate freeze okay
ah
okay good yeah technically yeah you're
right chaos is contained
uh this thing come in phantom you've got
the all clear
they'll never know what hit them maybe
not that's right
yeah i've got it
i mean technically yeah that worked see
the center for chaos containment sure
has a little surplus of nuclear bombs
yeah they do it's weird it's very weird
oh okay this is that
[Music]
gabe gg
oh
what's going on
[Music]
uh hell yeah all right well hell yeah
a uh chief yeah we got a tank
approaching
with henry inside
henry you're here what are you doing in
a tank
repeat that raid has been aborted
fallback
you protected the clan yeah
the future of the topic fan looks right
with you as our leader
hell yeah baby top hat for life
uh i kneel on the first time rope
yes
oh it's a worm's reference
okay climb like a normal person would
if only i knew if only i actually played
breath of the wild
all right and then walk through
hey everyone this is part 65 of my henry
stickman playthrough
today i'm going to be doing the part
with the tank
but uh before i get started i just want
to thank my sponsor
if you like the video just punch that
punch the like punch the subscribe
um slap this the support button well
then i got the
red hair girl from fleeing the complex
she comes in oh there are
she's the big tank and you want to
choose walk through here and it uh makes
a guy come out and
he keeps saying like welcome back to
part 65 of my walkthrough
before i get started make sure to like
comment subscribe on my video has a lot
of fails in it i'm only like halfway
through it
brings you up to three choices um
when you select walkthrough plays a
video of this guy doing a walkthrough
he keeps saying like hey everyone
playing
henry stickman today i'm gonna do a
walkthrough here
oh make sure you leave a comment it's
very important
it helps me out uh this part's a huge
spoiler so if you don't want to see
you should probably close your and when
you get to this tank part you want to
pick
walk through it'll play this video of a
guy who
starts talking and he's like hey what's
up
guys time for another walk through this
part
65 henry stickman gaming
don't forget to like don't forget to
comment uh don't forget uh
to subscribe to our fault i wouldn't
expect that to show up in here but i
guess they could do
anything we're in the tent now
how long does this go this super boring
guy
who just says what's up guys playing
interesting
today doing a walkthrough
follow me on instagram if i'll be on
facebook i'll be on
follow me on pin i can't believe
they're able to reference
this really obscure all right now so now
you're at the oh my god
quick walk through you get this big
gumbo hey
oh my god remember to ring the bell
remember to uh
comment if you liked the video oh look
like 400 000 how long
now you'll come up to a big tank and if
you choose to walk through here
oh my god this guy who's all hey guys
back to the video again playing uh henry
stickman today
make sure you watch till the end of the
video i'm doing a special giveaway
yeah they're bringing that guy for the
helicopter in the headset he comes in at
this park
tank you get three options you want to
pick walk through here
uh oh my god it goes up to this
welcome back to part 65 of my henderson
playthrough walkthrough i got a patreon
account
i feel like uh supporting me some more
oh yeah more
[Music]
hey what's up guys for another walk
through this
part 65 oh my god oh my god wait did it
just loop through
did it loop through expect this not to
work but you know
no it's not looped through tank you get
options
that's different
oh my god whatever the number on the
scrolling keeps going
up
this
the number is going up start playing a
video that's really boring
it's going up what's going on playing i
understand
today what's going on i'm still here
i'm still here guys guys i'm still
[Music]
if you click
i'm such a big dumbo i'm a big dumbo
guys make sure you leave a comment
make sure you leave a comment very
important it helps me out
you get three options you didn't mention
the memberships he's got to mention the
membership to go to become a member
there is no end to this there's no end
to this
i bet there's no end to this there is
no end it's just there's numbers that
it's like a program to make the numbers
increase no matter how hard he scrolls
because it's up to 5000
now hey guys it's gonna be a walk
i'm gonna get up and go to the bathroom
and then maybe get a snack
and i'm gonna see back to the video
again if anything happens it'll be
recorded
i will not see it myself but i will know
that it happened subscribe on my video a
guy who
starts talking and he's like welcome
back to
part 65 of my henry stickman playthrough
walkthrough
uh make sure you watch till the end of
the video i thought that if i walked
away
or do something to show up in here but i
guess they could do
anything
all right now so now you're at the tank
if you pick walk through you get this
big dumbo long do i let it go
i could look up a walkthrough of how
long this takes
but wouldn't that just be the most
ironic thing that could happen
out of this choice and i will not let
that happen
this game has a lot of fails in it i'm
only like halfway through
oh my god it's it's it's it no
oh my god oh my god
oh my god hijack oh yeah i forgot we're
playing a game
let's do this
oh
all right and i forgot to signal yeah
okay at least it's over at least
it's over at least
it's over there's only two left and then
finding all what the little things do
okay we got this
i am top hat material ellie is gone
okay three days after fleeing the
complex yes
hi it's me
how did you get here oh i'm ellie i
heard the guy i helped escape was the
leader of the top act clan so i busted
myself out and followed him
i helped you escape and you just left me
what have you no honor no dignity
actions like this tarnish the tuppet
name
is this really what we want out of a
leader
in here took control of the topic plan
for himself
he's not worthy of being our leader hey
we throw him overboard
who's with me uh oh
why are we doing this i thought henry
was a pretty good leader
yeah you know this doesn't really take
any loyalists to break
henry you are hereby dethroned from your
position as leader of the tuppet clan
[Music]
oh jump or i'll make you jump
i will not jump save state i'm gonna beg
a digit i don't want to hear it oh
oh okay all right then same state
shot through the leg and you're to blame
you give seize a bad name well you know
i thought i got shot in the balls so
that's marginally better chainsaw
yeah idiot
[Music]
hmm definitely thought the other side
would fall like all of the cartoons
helicopter hat see around nerd
idiot hello uh
hi oh hey what's up i let you out a
while ago i don't know what that ever
did we're with you henry
get us out of here
dave dave dave you got this
oh oh thanks dave good teamwork good
teamwork dave
that's a big key thanks henry no problem
no huh the denouncement
ceremony has been completed henry is no
longer the leader of the top that clan
hmm how do you want to proceed boss i
got a few ideas
uh good chance deuces midnight surprise
oh my goodness these are
the good gents ah that was a close call
henry's still the leader i've had enough
of this
oh my god
all right fair enough uh midnight
surprise
oh oh well that's a lot of things thank
you again for rescuing me from
now
all right for enough deuces
i mean it works oh
[Music]
what
what what
what was that
oh they're dead i looked down for saying
i got a call
i missed it what happened did we kill
him are they dead oh
interesting oh interesting
interesting very interesting
poppy
what'd you do with henry
[Laughter]
hilarious mind crystal the sims
oh
shaloob
that's very funny okay that was a that
was a very short one which means that
the
it looks like the last one is going to
be one of the long long ones which is
good thing i saved it for last
oh this is a little i'm so sad this is
the last path
it's the last path it's the last path
no patience are nearly complete yes
yes so
this is the top hat clan secret base
yeah you impressed me
oh what happened to that guy
henry you're back he
took charge and you're stead i hope you
don't mind
uh i'm ellie i'm new here what are you
guys up to
well uh henry remember that orbital
station
idea we were talking about maybe we went
ahead with that plan
all of our assets in there already
preparations are complete we'll be ready
to launch into orbit
that should keep us far away from any
governments trying to bring us down
hey what did i tell you about calling me
that henry is the chief remember
okay we're under attack
oh you two get to the rocket henry
one two three the rocket is launching in
five minutes
do something i will do something
very accurate targeting system
[Music]
super punch excellent
i oh my god oh
uh grappling yuck give
give take that
see you later
i'll see you until my friend gets here
i'll see ya
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes oh wait no uh wait
oh
bomb has been planted wait i have to go
back
i have to go back just because i know
what this other one was
this is the greatest plan
sorry i just had to do that one all
right
you know how it is man let's do this
[Music]
style on them
nice excellent what did that do
all right well fair all right fair at
least he's dead
george henry
[Music]
henry all right i want to go back
actually i was just like
boomerang
nailed nailed nailed excellent owl
oh revolver
it's high noon
nice okay i'm sorry i
summoned
i love it
[Laughter]
all right fair enough dual tech
how what
the hell happened
wow i don't understand that it's
launching in
one minute we gotta hurry
you guys need a ride yeah
don't wanna get through man we've got
company
ah wait
all right all right henry's got this
oh my god
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait not without me
henry's still down there i'll keep the
door open as long as i can come on we
gotta go
no oh my god uh
the cloud
oh all right fair enough uh g inverter
and for gravity it's that simple
excellent uh
abandoned tank go baby go baby go
yeah i love it i love it
i love it thank you henry you know
i could drop you right now and nobody
would know
but why would i do that why would you do
that i saw you out there
put yourself on the line to save the top
ed plan
you've truly earned my respect i can't
think of a better person to lead us
[Music]
i did it i'm the best
i'm the greatest there ever was we were
able to establish our orbital station
unfortunately we lost quite a few
members during the raid
with the station in orbit we were able
to raid any place on earth
ellie was officially recruited into the
tuppet clan and given the rank
right-hand lady me and my right-hand man
went on to become top
operators in the clan performing several
successful operations
beautiful top hat king
[Music]
i love it there's only
oh there's only two ah there's only two
i haven't gotten
oh oh ellie
right right okay fair enough all right
don't want to get through man we won't i
mean we will
i mean we won't actually right hand man
he's got it baby
no this story ends over shot by a little
bit oh no
oh no oh no
wait why don't i have any cards wait
what the hell
what wait what are these cards
right click a character when you see him
to unlock the car
what but how am i why what do you mean
what in the what wait a minute
what what is that what in the half
in the half
what in there wait okay
there's one more thing there's one more
thing i can do
there really is one more thing that i
can do
if if i can't believe there are bios
here too
my god i never would have thought to
right click on anything i wasn't
right-clicking on anything
but if i get all the fails there was
that you remember the chaos thing
there was something under the sticky
notes so i'm gonna find that
god what would it take to do all of
these bios here
that seems like so much work yeah
look at these bio look at all the by all
the bios
sir place your hands where i can see
them
[Laughter]
oh god i forgot about that
okay all right that is everything
all of the fails so now what i need to
do
is i need to go here and i need to go
to the one that had chaos
choices which one of these
here this boom boom
boom and this
is the last thing i can do multiverse
imbalance
fix
alert multiverse level of capacity
initializing multiverse defragmentation
and only detected correcting
anomaly
[Music]
oh package huh oh you did yep
i got a package here for someone named
henry i love delivering packages
what
oh
oh that's right
who the hell sent the package in the
first oh
oh
oh my god
that was so thoughtful
that's really the thing that i can say
about this series is
it's so thoughtful it's thinks
about everything or it tries to anyway
and it tries to be imaginative and
original and
and man what a treat what
an honest-to-goodness treat this whole
series was
this game i don't know if puffballs is
ever going to make another one
i definitely don't know how you would go
off of the myriad of
endings that was in completing the
mission let's look at all these it would
be almost insane to try to do this again
uh but to be perfectly honest i think
that this style of humor
needs to thrive and i think that
puffballs
deserve success for the accomplishment
of this
years in the making literally years
in the making i don't know when the
first one came out but my goodness
what a treat support the developer the
link to this game is in the description
there's so many other collectibles like
look at all of the freaking
bios like the idea the the amount of
work that you would have to put in just
to make all of these characters
clickable is
nuts i never even thought about that and
they all have names and they all live
it's crazy and there was collectibles
when i was in the stealing the diamond
i didn't even realize you could click on
the paintings i didn't even know that
was a thing maybe i knew before but i
did
i didn't remember that's crazy
this is awesome thank you puffballs for
making this and thank you everybody so
much for watching it and enjoying it
please support this like it's so worth
it there's so much fun to be had
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to check out the other
videos i've done on this one
they're in the description below and
thanks again
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you